The Joe Rogan Experience can I tell you
this story it's a bit of a story but
it's fun to tell so I had wrote like 100
songs last year and I didn't feel great
about any of them to be honest
um the label liked a few was trying to
pick radio singles but I just didn't
have no conviction about it Joe and my
daughter at the same time had found her
way into this little Back Road Church in
the middle of nowhere about a country
where we live
she kept asking me to come and you know
I have a tumulus relationship with the
Lord so I wasn't you know sure how I'd
show up but I was like you know what
I'll go and I went it was 100 people a
little Back Road Church you know 20 of
them were kids went to high school with
her and around the same time I caught
this little [__] smoking pot
right she's 15 she's doing 15 year old
kid stuff and I was like but he won't
believe it about about your age I
started making these same decisions and
I was going to this little bitty Church
in Antioch I told her the story of this
church she don't believe it so I take
her to this old church it's still there
it's called Whitsett Chapel Baptist
Church
and that night riding home with her I
didn't tell nobody but in my mind I
thought that's the album I'm writing
like [__] every song I wrote I'm writing
this album I called Zach Crowell he
produced every Sam Hunt song ever you
know one of the biggest producers in
town I've known in my whole life he's
here with me right now and uh
I said dude I want to write an album
called going to church and I just kind
of want to write this kind of Journey
and just kind of A to Z and write a real
project and Zach was like I'm in he's
like well why don't you just call it
Whitsett Chapel so that's how we ended
up doing with the chapel so when need a
favor came into the fold I was like
what's worship music for Sinners sound
like
like what is a [__] like me you
know because you know when you're in
church it's holy holy you were great I
was like I don't necessarily feel that
way so how do I feel you know what I
mean and then it was like I only talked
to God when I meet a favor you know and
I was like we got to build it with a
choir and big production I want that old
um stop clap you know that old church
feeling I want to bring like that Vibe
of that church you know into the into
that and the whole thing is the whole
album is built on that Vibe of like
there's fire in Brimstone there's
everything you go through in a Sunday
morning worship service if you've ever
been to a Sunday in the South worship
service they're gonna you're gonna
convince you you're a horrible human at
some point you're going to hell and then
at the end they'll hit a major key
instead of a minor one finally and go
but there's hope you know what I'm
saying so I was like
I was like how do I write that you know
man well I've always been a fan of those
preachers I love the way they they
Captivate an audience and even if
they're crazy even if they're talking
nonsense no there's something exciting
about watching some dude preach the word
and just yell it out and then fire on
fire so I gotta I got I'm gonna send you
a link to the album but I got a preacher
throughout the whole album doing that
Joe that tied the record together oh so
you ran like the album starts with this
dude like in by the grace of God we were
saved and it just drops the first song
it's cool man that's amazing I got nerdy
dude I went like old school dude I went
like back to the 90s I was in the studio
like we were just getting high and
coming up with [__] beautiful yeah it
was so much fun it was probably the most
fun I've ever had writing an album
because it's the first time I've sat
down a long time and wrote an album
instead of just writing a bunch of songs
and then picking an album you know what
I mean I was like no I'm right like
we're gonna sit down and write an album
so does that just came out of the blue
inspirationally yeah just I just wasn't
just felt like something to do and I'm
gonna get like all the way real I didn't
understand what was I had commercial
success for the first time in my life
and I didn't know how to deal with that
so you do what everybody does in that
moment I'm sure you may or may not have
been there in your career early where
you like you chase it then you're like
oh my God hold on I can be yeah and I
realized that the songs wouldn't sound
like jelly roll no more ah you know and
I was like no I'm doing the thing that
people do where they [__] their career
up I was like I'm not doing that man so
you think that that's just a normal trap
that happens to everybody that gets
success and they don't want to [__] up
that success so they try to make a
formula for what they think the people
liked about their early [__] yes yes 100
or they chase
whatever the poppy record was or
whatever the record that did the most so
it's like how do I write another song
like that so I was coming off of a hit
that I the one I gave you the plaque for
son of a sinner was my first radio hit
like hit hit
and I was like I didn't know how to come
out of it because I didn't write the
song for radio I wrote the song like I
wrote every other song but then you
start thinking oh I can write songs for
radio and I had [__] 70 radio songs
like [__] I'm not you know it's like nah
man I just need to I need to do what got
me to radio I didn't do what jelly roll
does and I was like I know what it is
I'm gonna get back on my Foxhole and
write me a [__] album dude you know
what I'm saying that's beautiful I took
it off music bro we went back to some
little old back ass studio in the
Backwoods and we wrote it kind of like
you know like we wrote all my early [__]
feel like it's like every level of
success that you get you're presented
with a unique problem that you haven't
seen before and it's up to you to just
figure it out just figure out what are
you doing this for and I think that
applies to Everything I Know it applies
to Comedy it definitely seems to apply
to music I think it probably applies to
everything figure out what you're doing
it for like why do you like to do I know
you have to make a living but once all
that's taken care of like what are you
doing it for you should be doing it for
the love of this thing whatever this
thing is that you do you are a love
spreading machine as a human being right
whether it's your love of carpentry
whether it's your love of electronics
what is it what's your thing man
everybody's got a thing but not
everybody finds a [__] thing that's
the problem with this world so people
get trapped in something that's not
their thing and that's that's what they
are now and they they don't ever get to
express themselves in a way that would
make them feel good well for me I always
call it the why and it's like what you
said even with the music and that's what
happened with those 70s songs when the Y
comes down to oh this is catchy or this
is a good song I'm past the point of
like if this I want to help people Joe
like my music has always been
therapeutic my music has always been for
people what got me into music was my
mother so my mother was a woman who
struggled with extreme mental health
issues and drug addiction and she would
never come out of a room Joe
and she would
she would come downstairs
and she'd throw a record on
she'd light a cigarette at the table
and dude I would watch the house change
like
brothers sisters cousins coming from
across the street going in a little
tight neighborhood poor people you know
Neighbors coming over her friends start
flooding the house and she held Court
Joe I would watch our kitchen turn into
a nightclub and she'd start telling
stories and listen we didn't have Google
we had to believe the [__] back right
you know what I'm saying like
you know what I'm saying so she would be
like James Taylor wrote this about his
drug addicted mother you know what I'm
saying there's something to play Fire
and Rain but she'd be like Bette Midler
wrote The Rose about we're just like all
captivated and then she'd play The Rose
and we're all crying in the kitchen
together and it's like and I didn't
understand because I'm a kid right but
something changed in her when the record
went on is how I looked at him I didn't
know anything about drug addiction
anything about schizophrenia or bipolar
or any of this stuff she was dealing
with her manic depression back then what
they called I didn't know any of this I
just knew that this lady never [__]
leaves that room and when she does it
seems like the music doesn't
so I spent my whole life writing songs
for her right I was like I kind of
indirectly was like writing these songs
for the addicted and the Broken You know
what I mean because that's what I was
seeing yeah so it's like I found purpose
in the music and like I tell people if I
was going to do it for money like any
sane [__] comedian or musician I'd
have quit 10 years ago because [__] I
wouldn't I didn't make any for 15 years
you know if I was doing it for money I'd
quit forever ago and went and got a job
I just knew that it was always helping
people you know what I mean it's like
the music was all because I seen how it
helped my mother
and I knew the power of music and to
this day like when you first bring up
music I'm like I'm a mood guy it's like
you know you know how I feel about what
I gotta go listen to like yeah to this
day if I'm going through something in
life I'll grab a joint go hop in a
pickup truck and tell my wife I'll be
back and she knows what I'm doing I'm
just gonna go listen to music for an
hour and smoke a joint I'm gonna come
back and sort through this [__]
but it was something about that that
made me want to write songs for purpose